Thank you so much, Dr. Cannon, for presenting this very important data.
Now I would like to invite Dr. Tiger, Assistant Professor of Medicine at Mayo Clinic, to talk about the safety of peripheral IV anthracycline-based lymphoma regimen.
Hi, I'm Claire Tiger. Thank you so much for giving me the opportunity to present this data.
Actually, this was picked as a lender list number one last year at ASH 2025, so I'm very excited to share this data.
Today, I'm going to tell you about the use and safety of peripheral IV versus central venous catheter for lymphoma patients receiving frontline anthracycline-based chemotherapy.
My disclosures, extravasation of vesicants and infiltration of irritants are potential risks during anthracycline administration.
To mitigate these risks, ports and picks are commonly used, but there are several limitations to using these.
They require procedure replacement, so you need a surgeon or interventional radiologist.
They can delay therapy.
If you are not a surgeon or interventional radiologist, the patient may not be able to continue the treatment if you are not in the emergency room.
They can cause infections, thrombosis, and mechanical complications, and they certainly add health care costs.
Before I go further into more details, I think it's really important to define these terms because extravasation is very loosely used in our field.
And so in order to do this study right, we went back to the literature and defined these terms very clearly.
So extravasation is an extravenous administration.
So extravasation is an extravenous administration of any vesicant solution that causes damage.
So there is no to minimal blood return, usually associated with swelling, and they predominantly manifest with erythema.
Infiltration is an extravenous administration of non-vesicant solution.
Phlebitis is inflammation of veins, inner lining.
Flare reaction is a transient, painless, skin-streaking erythema.
They usually resolve in one to two hours.
And vessel irritation is a pain.
Discomfort.
For tightness along the infused vessels with erythema, dark skin discoloration.
So risk of extravasation injury is pretty uncommon and has been pretty well studied.
They vary in account from 0.01 to 6.5%.
The biggest studies were encompassing all types of solid tumors and oncology in general that looked at over 730,000 infusions.
And they documented 673 extravasation events.
Making up 0.09%.
The studies have also reported some patient-related risk factors with extravasation.
So advanced age, poor functional status, the quality of veins.
And then there are operator and technical risk factors, such as limited experience, multiple attempts, and how fast you're infusing the chemotherapy.
In academic centers, PIV has been utilized for select frontline chemotherapy regulations.
But because there's a lack of data on effectiveness and safety, a lot of the community centers and some of the academic centers default to using central venous catheter.
So this study really is to look at complications of PIV versus central venous catheter in administering CHOP and AVVD-based chemotherapy.
This was a multi-center retrospective study from eight U.S. centers, seven academic and one community.
And the use of PIV.
PIV versus CBC was at center or provider discretion.
This included patients over 18 with a newly diagnosed Hodgkin or non-Hodgkin lymphoma receiving CHOP or AVVD-based regimen.
Treated between 2010 to 2025.
If you were receiving continuous infusion like dosage of CDPOC, you were excluded.
And if you weren't receiving anthracycline, then you were also excluded.
Primary endpoint was extravasation.
Total, we looked at over 1,400 patients.
CBC and PIV.
In general, had the similar patient characteristics.
But I do have to point out that stage 3, 4 were higher in CBC arm and ECOG 0, 1 were higher in the PIV arm.
In general, the types of lymphoma were very similar between the two arms.
And the types of chemotherapy that were administered between the two arms were very similar.
Three-fourths of patients from the CBC arm used the port-a-cath and a quarter of patients used the PIC.
So here is the data.
In total, there were about 4,000 cycles in the CBC and 3,600 cycles in the PIV.
And 4,900 infusions in the CBC and 4,400 in the PIV.
The reason there is a discrepancy between cycles and infusion is because AVVD have two infusions per cycle.
In total, there was only one extravasation reported in the PIV arm.
This was a 70-year-old man who received polituzumab ARCHIP and had a chronic vascular damage with necrosis.
It's requiring debridement and grafting.
So there was one case of chronic vascular damage.
There were two other cases of suspected extravasation.
These were really limited information given the nature of retrospective data analysis.
And we couldn't further analyze them.
And so we put them under suspected extravasation.
But they did not have a chronic vascular damage.
There was one case of infiltration with the CBC and six cases with the PIV.
And there were six cases of flare in the PIV, but there were no documented vascular damage with these.
There were higher incidence of DVT with the central venous catheter at 17 and four cases with the PIV.
And they all started anticoagulation.
There was three cases of superficial venous thrombosis with PIV, which was treated with supportive care.
Now, you might ask, how do you account for DVT with the PIV?
That is a limitation of the retrospective.
And so we basically said if you developed DVT in the upper extremity while you're getting the PIV,
or getting chemotherapy, we counted that toward the DVT for the PIV arm.
The phlebitis was much higher in the PIV, and this was significantly higher.
The cellulitis and sepsis were higher in the CVC arm.
There were five reported cases of sepsis with the CVC, but none reported with the PIV.
Erythema, swelling, catheter malfunction were similar, but pain was significantly higher with the PIV arm.
There were a total of 163 patients that switched.
Between one modality to another, 129 received the PIV, then switched to CVC.
The reasons for switching were really limited based on the nature of retrospective.
And so there were significant patients that were not reported for the reasons why they changed.
Because age was one of the risk factors for extravasation, we did do a subgroup analysis for patients over 80 years old.
This group was a little bit smaller.
So CVC had an 89 patient.
PIV arm.
PIV arm had 122 patients.
In general, they were pretty similar in nature and in terms of their types of lymphoma and the chemotherapy that they received.
And there were 400 cycles in the CVC arm, 577 in the PIV arm, and 425 infusions in the CVC and 587 in the PIV arm.
There were no extravasation that was reported.
And the one case of suspected extravasation was the same one that we had reported previously in the entire cohort.
There were no chronic vascular damage.
There were one cases each of the infiltration of chemotherapy, two cases of flare and phlebitis in the PIV arm.
But there were higher cases of cellulitis and DVT in the CVC arm compared to the PIV arm.
This is a limited number, but PIV seems to have a similar safety profile as the CVC and appears to be a safe option even for elderly population.
So in total, I have looked at over 1,400 lymphoma patients and over 9,300.
There were over 1,400 anthracycline treatment infusions.
Only one confirmed case of extravasation and chronic vascular damage was reported, making up 0.02% of all total infusions.
Other than that, there were no other reported vascular damages.
And there were fewer DVTs and sepsis associated with PIVs compared to CVC, but more pain and phlebitis.
So use of PIV is safe and it appears to be an effective option for anthracycline-based regimen for treatment of lymphoma.
my acknowledgement.